back now at 7 30 on cbs mornings and
we're learning about an alarming trend
involving some nursing homes what starts
out as a good deed helping a loved one
to get into one of those homes can turn
into a legal nightmare in some cases our
partner kaiser health news along with
npr has been looking into nursing homes
that have filed lawsuits against not
only residents but also their friends
and family all in an effort to collect
unpaid bills our consumer investigative
correspondent anna werner has the story
81 year old barbara robinson spent the
past two years fighting a lawsuit all
because she volunteered to help an
elderly friend of her mother's move to
this county run nursing home in
rochester
they caused me
a lot of grief it all began in february
2018 when robinson agreed to act as
power of attorney to help the friend
file for medicaid to pay for the nursing
home and then move in a lot of pressure
for me to get that done and get it in
there because they needed to get her
signed up but then the nursing home
asked robinson to sign this admission
agreement saying she would be the
responsible party ensuring they'd get
paid
so i said i'm in no way can be
responsible for this woman's bill she
says nursing home staff told her not to
worry she wouldn't be because if they
had said to you well yeah ultimately
you're going to be responsible what
would you have said well i couldn't have
signed it i couldn't have signed it i
there was no way i i've been social
security yet after the friend passed
away the county sued her for 21 thousand
dollars in unpaid bills even though she
no longer had power of attorney a judge
later dismissed the lawsuit i thought
you can't do that to somebody
you can't just knock on somebody's door
and say you need to pay this bill but
come to find out
they could in fact in robinson's area of
rochester alone a kaiser health news
review of court records found that over
a three-year period 24 federally
licensed nursing homes filed 238 similar
lawsuits two-thirds of which targeted
relatives of residents or friends
federal laws prohibit nursing homes from
requiring third parties including
relatives or friends to guarantee
payment of bills but attorney anna
anderson says this is
a growing problem and it's only getting
worse we will go ahead and file
everything she says people she has
represented have been sued after signing
admissions agreements even if they're
not legally responsible i don't think
anyone that i've met when they're
signing these papers even when they ask
the right questions i don't think they
really understand what they're signing
up for
why is that well the language is very
confusing the nation's largest nursing
home industry group the american health
care association told us we haven't
heard of our members doing this and we
do not believe it's a widespread
practice robin king says it happened to
her in cleveland she was sued after
helping move her 86 year old mother into
a nursing home in 2017
i was shocked i was
in disbelief she says she had carefully
read the paperwork and made clear she
could not pay her mother's bills there
was one paper we came across and it said
will you be financially responsible if
your mom cannot pay this and i was like
no absolutely like new x marks the spot
yet three years later the nursing home
sued her for over 78 thousand dollars
earlier this year she testified in front
of a senate committee
there must be a better way to take care
of each other and not leave people like
me facing life-changing amounts of debt
there's just no excuse for this in
america barbara robinson says she's
angry too
it's like they look around who can we
try and get this money out of
robin king was dropped from the lawsuit
filed by her mother's nursing home but
the home is still seeking funds from her
mother's estate neither nursing home
responded to our request for comment but
monroe county in new york that's where
barbara robinson's the home where she
took her friend her mother's friend told
kaiser and npr that it would be a
disservice to the hospital's residents
and to monroe county's taxpayers to
allow residents who have assets not to
pay what is owed robinson however says
the friend basically had no assets nate
anna thank you
wow that is eye-opening and you're just
trying to help a friend and she was very
clear when she said no no yeah i still
get the better you still get sued yeah
do you still get it the federal law
prohibits these nursing homes from suing
friends and family right can't you just
use that as your reason not to pay these
bills yes but your heart's still going
to start beating when you open that
envelope and it says 78 thousand dollars
you are right about that even when you
think you're right tony i think it's
very unsettling yeah definitely